writing a one punch man workout was
always going to be a little different
from writing other workouts inspired by
fictional characters
the obvious reason for this is that we
already know saitama's entire training
his workout infamously consists of 100
push-ups
100 setups
100 squats and 10 kilometers of running
the joke is that this simple routine was
able to get him to the point where he
could jump from the moon to the earth
and
punch giant meteorites into dust it's
just goofy fun
so what more is there to say first i
want to address this workout as it's
written
to see what merits it actually has
secondly i want to create a revised
version that will offer real benefits
and it turns out that this workout
even as written may be more effective
than you would think
the first thing to address is that
saitama's program is pretty incomplete
for most purposes
is that one set of 100 push-ups or is it
10 sets of 10
what order are we completing these in
and where is the progressive overload
here
what happens when 100 push-ups becomes
really easy the one punch man workout is
also a little imbalanced
there are no pulling movements
whatsoever let alone twisting or
extension
and you're likely to find that 100
sit-ups is a lot easier than 100
push-ups
and much easier than a 10 km run
going that far every single day is going
to either take a considerable amount of
time
or be quite hard on the old joints still
there are ways around this and there are
mitigating factors
so let's take a look at the good stuff
for a moment i recently posted an
article over at thebioneer.com called
the surprising benefits of doing 100
push-ups a day or more
i'll be repeating some of that here but
check it out if you want some more
background
i'm assuming here that what saitama
actually meant was that he would
complete a single set of 100 push-ups
and that this should be tough doing this
has surprising benefits
firstly if you're going to failure or
close to failure then you'll be
recruiting
larger faster twitch muscle fibers even
with this relatively low amount of
weight
that's because all the slow twitch
muscle fibers will fatigue and give up
leaving only the more powerful motor
units to keep you going
this in turn means you can develop
strength through high rep calisthenics
despite what you may think in short your
91st
rep of your 100 rep max feels and acts
similar to lifting 91 of your one rep
max
not exactly the same mind but it will
have many of the same benefits
i took a 10 month hiatus from bench
press during the current pandemic
and returned for the first time last
week i decided to ease myself back into
it but i was pretty comfortable
performing five reps of 125 kilograms
and that was with incomplete recovery
from my previous set
because that's how i roll point is high
rep push-ups and some calisthenics
variations
were enough to let me maintain most of
my strength
better yet is that this type of training
builds strength endurance
this is something i've mentioned in the
past but i believe it is severely
overlooked
point is it's not all that useful being
able to lift something really heavy
just once far more useful is being able
to lift something heavy
lots of times or hold it in place for a
long time i don't get why more people
don't focus on this aspect of their
performance
and it's something i think crossfit has
gotten very right the anecdote i
always come back to is tom platts who
would do a hundred plus reps on the leg
press every single day
to build his massive legs he could
eventually perform a hundred reps of
squats
with 225 pounds on his back that's
extremely insane and to me it's one of
the most exciting examples
of an alternative approach to training
far more impressive than
a single extremely heavy squat just give
it a go if you
aren't already impressed with this of
course this method did involve
progressive overload unlike the one
punch man approach
but the point is that he was using high
reps to failure or close
to get there that's what 100 push-ups or
air squats will be for most people
and doing all those squats isn't that
far removed from the kind of training
used by the great gamma
or mike tyson to build a massive
powerful legs either
check out my bane training video for
more on that this strength endurance
comes with a number of other unique
adaptations
what's really interesting is that this
might improve blood supply to the
muscles
this occurs in part through angiogenesis
or capillarization
the formation of new tiny blood vessels
that both carry blood to the muscles
and also take waste products away from
them such as the hydrogen ions
that cause muscle burn and fatigue the
result is not only greater energy supply
during a set but also more efficient
removal of waste
which in turn helps to go for longer
this is amazing for preventing
injuries too because you'll be providing
the tendons with greater blood supply
it also means more recovery between
workouts because getting more blood to
the muscles
helping you to handle the repetitive
grind of doing anything daily like this
so the high rep stuff is good but i feel
that a hundred sit-ups is a little out
of place
and we really need something for pulling
in there i'd recommend using bodyweight
rows to balance out with the push-ups
why because the row more closely matches
the push-up both in terms of the number
of reps you can do
and in terms of the biomechanics one of
the great surprising benefits of push-up
training like this
is that if you're doing them correctly
by not allowing your waist to sag to the
ground
then you'll also be strengthening your
core for greater performance
it's like moving plank especially at
these higher rep ranges
the bodyweight row is perfect for
offering the same stability
in the opposite direction anti-extension
that's because you now need to prevent
your buttocks from touching the ground
i've talked about this in much more
depth in a very recent video so make
sure you check out that if you haven't
seen it already
and if it's punching we want then we
also need to train the transverse plane
the body's ability to twist on the spot
that's why i'd recommend swapping the
sit-up
for at least bicycle crunches or better
yet alternating v-ups returning to the
hollow body position between each rep
adding some training for the obliques
this way not only makes sense for a
one-punch mana workout
but also provides a more complete
midsection development many people will
find that performing
sets of 100 reps is tough on all of
these exercises
if that goes for you then simply aim to
complete the sets in as little time as
possible
that means you'll be aiming to keep the
rest time between sets as small as you
can
this results in an incomplete recovery
turning it into a form of metabolic
conditioning
in short it still helps you to get
better at removing metabolites and keeps
your heart rate up
it might take you an hour to do 100
push-ups the first day but in a few
months you'll be bashing out sets of 100
under a minute the adaptations here come
fast
if you can't do a single push-up or
squat then you can make the movement
easier you can perform squat pulses
shout out to the awesome jax blade who
covered this topic in his saitama video
or you can use push-ups on your knees
complete as many reps using proper form
as you can and then drop immediately to
the easier variation
this is called a mechanical drop set and
i'm all about that
and if you're facing the other problem
and you find that this is all too easy
then you can use the same strategy in
reverse do explosive push-ups or
weighted push-ups
then drop to the normal variation
remember the benefits of doing high-rep
calisthenics
come partly from going to or near
failure
those not interested in performing the
one punch man workout but keen to get
the benefits
can try using long drop sets in their
training or incorporating flush sets
a flush set means that you might end
your chest workout with 100 reps on the
chest press
which is a fantastic way to create an
immense burn while also actually
enhancing recovery
but we can't talk about saitama's
training without addressing the running
portion
as i mentioned the 10 km run is a little
out of place in this equation
given that it's a lot harder when
performed daily or at least it is if you
go fast
take it much slower by which i mean
maybe running it in one hour and 30
minutes or even longer
and it shouldn't be too hard on the
bones and joints nor should it result in
too much burnout
this is a big mistake that a lot of
people make with their cardio
throwing in junk miles at something just
below their anaerobic threshold and
weighing themselves down over time
in his book beyond training ben
greenfield discusses how this can do
more harm than good
the irony is that humans are meant to
run long distances
some theories suggest that this is the
main way we would have survived in the
wild
and indigenous tribes like the tara
hamara seem to support that notion
long time viewers know that these are
the guys who run up to 435 miles over
two days
the difference is that they would run
those distances very slowly just as i
described
running is not just about cardio
performance it's about form and muscle
tone
don't go as fast as you physically can
to begin with just enjoy it and aim to
complete the distance in any time
you can even walk and this will actually
enhance recovery
by improving circulation not to mention
the obvious calorie burn benefits
that said if this is taking you all day
then i'm sure no one will judge you for
sticking to 5 km
and as you do run focus on your form
relax the shoulders keep the joints
stacked
ideally run in minimal footwear and use
a four foot stride
keep the core tight and don't let
yourself lean forwards or back too much
there are many more benefits you get
from mindful gentle running and walking
in fact i made a series of guided runs
and walks for a company called ifit
there i discuss these benefits and talk
about how you can focus more on your
form as you go
i'm showing clips from the trailer up on
the screen right now you can check that
out if you're interested in this stuff
and there's a three month trial i think
being mindful of your form and
maintaining this throughout your runs
will make everything tighter and
stronger
and it will help you to perform better
when fatigued if you feel pain in your
feet
knees or back then stop assess your form
and come back to it
if you're looking for an alternative
that will bring some of the same
benefits
look for something like the 100 up this
movement involves jumping from one foot
to another
to improve your hip stability as though
running on the spot but bringing these
up high
this is also a great way to check your
form and improve your form when fatigue
i'll make a video on this topic alone in
future but some claim it could
completely transform your running game
g walter george who invented the
technique apparently used to go from an
inexperienced runner to one of the best
of his time
this was during the 1800s so there you
go
that's my take on why so many people
have seen some pretty decent results
from the one punch man workout switching
to such high reps is a frightening
prospect for bodybuilders and
powerlifters
used to sets of 12 and 4 respectively
but it brings its own rewards
rewards that don't necessarily translate
to bigger numbers in the gym
which can be extremely beneficial in
life and in competition
and can result in a pretty mean physique
i'm not saying do this instead i'm just
saying
maybe consider those higher reps the
other really appealing thing about this
type of training of course is just that
it's so
simple if you've tried to follow complex
training programs in the past
and found yourself getting muddled and
confused then the idea of just picking
four exercises and repeating them every
single day is probably really appealing
almost any exercise regime that's that
simple is going to leave
some things out this can be a great way
for somebody new to training to get
started and just to get into the habit
of doing something daily
building good habits and then they can
build on that
as they start to see their basic
strength and
conditioning improve if you want to
learn more about performing high rep
calisthenics
then i actually have a free training
program you can get from the link in the
description
that's the bodyweight max stimulus
program
if you want something more in depth that
covers every aspect of strength and
performance
that improves strength mobility running
speed jump height reception brain
function and more
then of course you can check out my full
ebook and training program
super functional training that's on
discount right now during the pandemic
and it explains all of this in much more
detail finally if you want to learn all
about functional training and how it
applies to your real life or sports and
athletics
where it came from then you can
pre-order my physical book
functional training and beyond that will
be released early next year and it's
available at a discounted price if you
pre-order now
i hope you enjoyed this video guys and
found it useful and interesting if you
did then please consider leaving a like
and sharing it around
that helps me out so much thank you so
much for all your support this year
it's actually been a crazy year for the
bioneer and i also hope you all have a
fantastic christmas or
holiday season and that 2021 is a better
year for everyone
it can't be worse right thanks a ton for
watching guys
and bye for now